[Music]
food for thought
pills three times a day all your
nutrients all your favorite flavors feel
like having Lobster for breakfast
done trying to like mushrooms but you
can't stand the texture problem solved
meal replacement pills are the future at
least that's what people have been
saying for the past century so what if
we got them now how would they affect
our diet would we be healthier could
they solve world hunger will we see them
in our lifetime this is what if and
here's what would happen if you could
get your meals in a pill meal pills
began as a feminist ideal leading up to
the 1893 Chicago World's Fair the
American Press Association asked writers
to predict the world of 1993 so American
suffragettes Mary Elizabeth Lise
described a world of synthetic food
freeing women from kitchen work and
other domestic chores in the decades
that followed science fiction novelists
playwrights filmmakers and others from
different disciplines all experimented
with the idea of meal replacement pills
the best we've come up with so far is
Soylent Soylent is a thick and creamy
concoction that contains all the fat
carbs proteins vitamins and minerals you
need in a day so if we can drink our
meals why can't we pop them it wouldn't
be hard to replace a portion of your
diet with nutrient pills after all you
can pick up every essential vitamin in
pill form at your local grocery store or
pharmacy in doing so you might think
you're pretty nutritious and intelligent
but you wouldn't look it you'd grow
irritable depressed tired and you'd
eventually die of starvation because
it's not just nutrients we need to
survive calories are crucial the average
adult needs 2,000 calories per day to
survive what does that look like here's
the breakdown for breakfast
eat two eggs a slice of bread two
tablespoons of peanut butter and a glass
of juice for lunch how about a turkey
sandwich carrots and dip a chocolate
chip cookie and a glass of milk and then
for dinner you could grill up some
salmon out of baked potato some steamed
broccoli and a cup of ice cream for
dessert and if you need a snack during
the day grab an apple and a granola bar
and you've hit 2,000 calories so how do
you fit all that into one pill you don't
you
and even if that is the most
concentrated source of calories you
can't fit enough of it into a single
pill but if you were set on subsisting
on a pill only diet then you'd have to
eat 450 calorie pills a day plus other
vitamins to get your needed nutrients
that's sort of how Soylent was invented
living in San Francisco with high rent
and a high grocery bill Rob Reinhart
thought to economize through chemistry
he found out what the body needed to
survive ordered the raw ingredients
mostly in powdered form tossed him in a
blender added water and mixed up a
healthy hardy cocktail Reinhardt's
grocery bill went from four hundred and
seventy dollars a month down to $50 with
a meal replacement pill we could imagine
a much more efficient world and one with
greater food security since future meals
would be easier and cheaper to
manufacture and send around the world
the effects of climate change today are
beginning to limit what we can grow
mangos and avocados for example are
among the fruits that are in decline
while farms around the world are seeing
fewer yields due to global warming and
increased droughts we may never get it
in one pill but it's possible if not
likely that full meal replacements are
the way of the future and if you're
afraid that all your favorite flavors
will disappear if all your food came in
a pill
don't be researchers at the Institute of
food research in Norwich England
recently found a way to put multiple
flavors into a single capsule and have
them released one at a time at different
intervals so what's the future of food
fast frugal and flavorful Bon Appetit
[Music]
you